today is International Children's Day
the nonprofit group Save the Children is
releasing a new report that underlines
the stark challenges and dangers facing
kids around the world the end of
childhood index evaluates countries by
several life-changing events that
disrupt childhood they include food
insecurity infant mortality violence
teen pregnancy and lack of education
among the findings the United States
ranks 36th out of 172 countries far down
the list of industrialized nations Joe
Biden is the former second lady of the
United States and board chair for Save
the Children Carolyn miles is the
organization's president and CEO they
are here for an interview you'll see
only on CBS this morning welcome to the
point of view someone yeah thank you for
putting this report together and let me
start with you dr. Biden the report
notes that the threats to children are
across the board regardless of my income
level or geography what's the what's the
threat well the threat is there are
several childhood Enders and we put
together a report that points out these
eight childhood Enders and and by the
way it's a global report and and tell us
what's happening to children all over
the world and and then we looked at the
United States and we can we used five of
those Enders and ranked our state's and
and so the United States globally became
36 that's what count I'm so surprised by
and I shouldn't be about where you were
born yes it affects the kind of
childhood you will have including your
health
that's your longevity and how the kind
of life you live that's right and that's
why for Save the Children this is so
important because the kind of childhood
that you have today is going to
determine the kind of world that we have
in 15 years and so looking at those
enders of childhood which again the
disparities are all across the board in
terms of you know things like violence
against children child marriage teen
pregnancy those are things that affect
children all over the world and what we
have to do is actually go after those
kids who are most losing out on
childhood and bring
to the front of it that's why is a
superpower why is the United States so
low on the list yeah I think the US you
know we have made progress and things
like high school graduation rates and
teen pregnancy but if you look at the
rest of the world we haven't made the
progress that everybody else was made we
got to invest more money by beyond money
what would you do
yeah beyond money I think we would get
everyone involved I mean we would get
parents involved and corporations
involved and NGOs involved and I think
everybody has a stake in making
improving on this problem and and we've
we've got to start working talking about
the next generation yeah talking about
the next generation just a phrase
childhood endures it gives me a little
bit of a chill what is the most common
childhood ender just I think it's such a
chilling phrase the most common well I
think the lack of education is a huge
piece because if you look actually at
these childhood Enders so there's we
look at things like early marriage and
early marriage is important in that it
ends a girl's childhood but it also ends
her education which means that her
future is going to be completely
different right child labor is another
issue but education is a key piece of
that you've done so much with education
I know certainly in your service and the
report found that 750 thousand US
students drop out of school each year
yeah and you know we made progress on
that I mean we did increase the the
dropout rate so our lowered the dropout
rate and increase the graduation rate
and we did invest a lot in teachers and
in community colleges but really there's
just so much more that we were there
jumping out Jill we're able to figure
that out well I think a lot of it is
problems at home I think drug use is a
big one you know we've just got to do
better we've just got to do better in
mentoring these kids through high
schools we spend a lot of time on early
education as well because getting kids
that first start and making sure that
they're reading well you know everything
depends on reading and that's
okay the early education is the key I
like how Carolyn you make the point
though that this is our future investing
in our children is investing in our
future and one of those things is that
twenty eight million children around the
world are displaced living in refugee
camps I know dr. Biden you just got back
from Jordan from Jordan Jordan with then
they have little or no access to
education or food or Y where will these
refugee camps you will yes that's right
where will they end up as adults
well it within the refugee camps that's
one of the things that save is working I
mean everywhere I've gone to see refugee
camps save has been there which is one
of the reasons why I was so honored to
be as to be chair of save and so we're
setting up education for those children
because without it they can't get jobs I
mean it's it's really crucial if there
is a decline in support for government
program uh-huh certainly here in the
United States who's going to pick up the
slack well I think like I said before we
all have it we all have a stake in this
and we've all got it work ought to be a
call to action and we're going to do it
we're doing it today we'd never let you
go because they're wrapping us up are
you aware that Joe Biden has launched a
political action committee which leads
some people to believe are you thinking
about running at 2020 that he hasn't
made up his mom you know Joe is not
going away and you know that all of you
I mean he loves politics he loves what
he's doing and he said he would stay
involved and so he set up this pact
because he's going to be involved in the
midterm elections and his devotion to
moonshot is deepen oh yes absolutely
we're going to keep working on our
cancer moonshot because we've got to
give hope to those families who are
suffering with loved ones with care
thank you so much for coming yeah thank
you okay thank you